[Musique]
madrid juin 2014 autour du palais royal
plus de 10000 espagnols se sont
rassemblés pour saluer leur nouveau roi
felipe 6 il vient tout juste de succéder
à son père juan carlos
on célébrait son couronnement le nouveau
monarque a fait organiser une grande
réception 2000 invités triés sur le
volet des ambassadeurs des ministres des
hommes d'église des grands patrons et
parmi eux un intrus cet étudiant de 20
ans au sourire jubilatoire s'est
incrusté à la soirée du roi
pour entrer au palais il a récupéré
l'invitation et la carte d'identité d'un
ami proche de la famille royale
on pourrait croire à une blague de
potache
mais quelques semaines plus tard coup de
tonnerre
[Musique]
le jeune homme au visage d'ange est
arrêté soupçonné par la justice d'être
au coeur du plus grand scandale d'état
que l'espagne ait jamais connu bonjour
bonjour à tous j'ai refusé de témoigner
comme le prévoit la loi
car tous les éléments du dossier n'ont
pas encore été transmis à mes avocats
c'est mon droit le plus stricte merci
beaucoup
ce jour là des millions d'espagnols
découvre à la une des journaux francisco
nicolas gomes églises y as aussitôt
surnommé par la presse le petit nicolas
les juges l'accusent d' usurpation
d'identité d'escroquerie de faux et
usage de faux
ce post adolescents auraient réussi à
infiltrer le plus grand parti politique
et mis en place un réseau de trafic
d'influencé jusqu'au plus haut sommet de
l'état
un système qui lui aurait permis de
soutirer des pots-de-vin aux plus grands
patrons d'espagne
chantage escroquerie et combinant tous
genres le petit nicolas serait même et v
un scandale sexuel impliquant un membre
du gouvernement
ça rapporte unis ils voulaient son
moment de gloire
pour moi c'est un crack ce mec
ce qu'il a fait c'est profiter de la
manière dont fonctionne le système
espagnol et en politique tout est
question d'influencés copinage qui est
ce jeune homme de 20 ans qui fait
trembler les plus puissants d'espagne
comment at il pu tromper l'ensemble des
élites enquête sur un scandale d'état
qui n'en finit pas de secouer la
monarchie espagnole
l'histoire du petit nicolas comme ans
dans ce quartier populaire du nord de
madrid
c'est ici au deuxième étage de cet
immeuble qu'il a grandi avec sa famille
l'appartement a été désertée depuis que
l'afer est sorti dans la presse
ils ont disparu ici dans le quartier on
n'en parle pas
fils unique d'un père coursier et d'une
mère sans travail renfermé taciturne le
jeune garçon bout des parties de
football entre gamins du quartier car
lui s'imagine un autre destin devenir
célèbre un événement va lui permettre de
concrétiser ses rêves
il a dix ans lors du décès du pape jean
paul ii lors d'un rassemblement à madrid
il se glisse habilement dans la foule
pour faire sa première apparition devant
les caméras de télévision
kenny pékin n'apparaissent que
représente pour toi le pape jean paul ii
moi il me paraissait une personne très
sainte
fasciné par la télévision avide de
reconnaissance
sa famille ne roule pas sur l'or alors
il s'autorise quelques libertés avec la
réalité
rocio étaient en classe avec lui dans
une école religieuse
elle se souvient d'un camarade à
l'imagination débordante prêt à tout
pour épater la galerie il n'avait pas
beaucoup d'amis comme il était seul il
avait besoin de mentir pour se faire des
amis il racontait que ses parents allait
lui acheter une voiture ou bien un
portable
on ne savait pas quand ça allait se
passer ni combien ça à l'écouté il
disait aussi qu'il allait organiser des
grandes fêtes chez lui afin que des
trucs étranges
un bagout à toute épreuve qui va lui
ouvrir les portes de la plus haute
institution du quartier la mairie
le petit nicolas demande à sa mère de
l'emmener au réunion publique du conseil
municipal
il y fait la rencontre de cet homme
miguel boto le maire conservateur de
l'arrondissement un garçon de 10 ans qui
s'intéressent à la politique ce n'est
pas fréquent
intrigué par l'éloquence du jeune
nicolas toujours tiré à quatre épingles
miguel boto se lient d'amitié et lui
faire ses premiers pas en politique
quelles étaient leurs relations pourquoi
l'élu at il pris le petit nicolas se
sont elles aujourd'hui
miguel boto préfère éluder la question
bonjour monsieur le maire je peux vous
interviewez depuis quand connaissez-vous
le petit nicolas je n'ai rien à dire
qu'est ce que vous dites à ceux qui
affirment que vous êtes son parrain en
politique depuis que le scandale a
éclaté
rares sont les hommes politiques qui ose
avouer leur amitié avec le petit nicolas
joseph car il membre du parti populaire
est l'un des seuls à avoir accepté de
nous parler il avoue avoir été fasciné
par la prestance du petit nicolas qui
s'est imposé à seulement 15 ans comme
président des jeunes du parti populaire
à madrid et quand je les rencontre est
pour la première fois j'ai eu
l'impression d'être face à un jeune
plein de qualités c'était quelqu'un qui
savait ce qu'il voulait il voulait faire
la politique
ça m'a plu un jeune qui dit je veux me
consacrer à la politique ça m'intéresse
j'ai tout eu cru qu'il venait d'une
grande famille l'espagnol car ils
s'exprimer très bien il semblait
vraiment bien pour ajouter à l'illusion
le fils de coursiers issu d'un milieu
populaire n'hésite pas à mentir sur son
passé et a falsifié sa carte d'identité
avec un simple feutre blanc il efface
son adresse et la remplace par une autre
plus prestigieuse pour faire croire
qu'il habite un quartier aisé de la
capitale résultat à 14 ans
le petit nicolas est devenu l'ami intime
de tous les cadres de la droite
espagnole
moyenne on ne filme et pas
et surtout du premier d'entre eux l'ex
premier ministre espagnol josé maria
aznar
sur cette vidéo on voit nicolas juste
derrière lui pour devenir un fidèle de
hre s'est marié asnar vous allez voir
que le jeune homme a déployé une
étonnante stratégie
david guetta travail pour une petite
radio espagnole il connaît bien nicolas
qui anime et la chronique politique de
son émission donc je vous présente mon
studio
c'est ici que venait le petit nicolas
pour commenter l'actualité
il l'a fait très souvent il a pu
observer de près les manigances de
nicolas d'abord gagner la confiance du
fils aznar et du coup comme son père les
voyez tout le temps ensemble
il a eu aussi confiance en lui nicolas
voulait tirer profit de cette formation
sa force c'est sa capacité à manier
toutes les situations nous ne fait
jamais rien au hasard
nicolas profite en effet de sa proximité
avec un sonar pour étoffer sa collection
de photos une tactique appliquée
méthodiquement lors de ses rencontres
avec tous les hommes politiques de
premier rang
l'actuel premier ministre espagnol
mariano rajoy ou encore le secrétaire
d'état au commerce
ils diffusent ensuite ces clichés sur
son compte facebook pour asseoir sa
légitimité
c'est ce que les experts appellent
l'effet halo c'est à dire que si vous
êtes entourés de gens plus intéressant
que vous vous devenez intéressant car il
vous met au même niveau que clair si
vous êtes avec ces gens c'est que vous
êtes des leur adressons nos veille
à seulement 15 ans nicolas a réussi son
premier pari devenir incontournable dans
le monde politique espagnole il gravite
parmi les élites du pays pour en tirer
profit
il va alors passer à la deuxième phase
de son plan
sa nouvelle cible les grandes
entreprises espagnoles et leurs
dirigeants
auprès de qui il va monnayer ses
services pour toutes sortes
d'arrangements boro et journaliste
d'investigation il a enquêté sur nicolas
est mis au jour ce qui ressemble à un
vaste trafic d'influencé
nicolas utilise la politique pour
devenir un puissant businessman
ce qui l'intéresse c'est l'argent par
exemple s'il vend aux entrepreneurs et
aux patrons de boîtes de nuit ses
relations avec la mairie de madrid pour
leur éviter des amendes ou encore leur
obtenir des permis de construire est
chez lui en échange ils touchent des
commissions nous tiens un restaurateur
de madrid
joint par téléphone a accepté de
raconter la négociation qu'il a eu avec
le petit nicolas
l'entrepreneur voulait obtenir une
autorisation pour exploiter la terrasse
de son restaurant le jeune garçon lui
donne alors rendez vous au ministère du
commerce
en dehors des heures d'ouverture pour
lui proposer un deal la licence contre
200 mille euros
encore un fait il m'a dit qu'il pouvait
avoir n'importe quel n'importe quel
autorisation il affirmé connaître le
maire de madrid a reconnu josé maria
aznar
je suis allé au ministère alors qu'il
était fermé ce que deux secrétaires
m'attendais l'union toute la négociation
s'est faite avec le jeune cela me
faisait halluciné car je me disais si un
gamin de 18 ans est capable de monter
tout cela il doit avoir de sérieux
contacts pas la poudre
pour organiser ces rendez vous secrets
nicolas s'installe dans cette somptueuse
villa située dans le quartier le plus
huppé de madrid 700 mètres carrés sur
trois étages prix du loyer 5800 euros
par mois nicolas cela fait mettre à
disposition gratuitement grâce à une de
ses nombreuses relations
steve savignac vous saviez qu'il vivait
ici qui est alors ça va oui tout le
monde le sait la maison appartient au
prince cyril de bulgarie mais il n'y
habitait pas ça s'est il allouait et la
personne qui est sûre locataires et bien
justement c'est le petit nicolas grâce à
son sens de l'esbrouffe et son culot
sans limite
nicolas devient en quelques mois un
intermédiaire incontournable entre
décideurs politiques et chefs
d'entreprise et il ne va pas s'arrêter
là
pour monter ses combines il n'hésite pas
à inventer des scénarios de plus en plus
incroyables comme ce jour là où le jeune
homme de 17 ans se fait passer pour un
émissaire du roi afin d'impressionner le
grand patron avec qui il a rendez-vous
ils montent de toutes pièces un cortège
officiel plus vrai que nature
fier de son coup il immortalise
l'instant voiture avec chauffeur
gyrophares
tout est faux nicolas a payé de sa poche
pour que l'illusion soit parfaite
miguel bernard et président d'une
association anti corruption
il a pu se rendre compte des talents
d'acteur de nicolas et de son formidable
appelons en toutes circonstances
il venait me récupérer la barre en bas
dans la rue avec une voiture officielle
un chauffeur et une escorte et il n'en
menait ensuite sur les lieux de nos
réunions des réunions qui se déroulait
souvent dans ce café lors de leur
rencontre
nicolas se faisait passer pour l'envoyé
du roi le petit jeu de l'usurpateur
était bien rodé
son téléphone sonne et il décrochait
solvay et revenez quelques instants plus
tard il disait que c'était un appel du
président ou du roi juan carlos miguel
bernard a porté plainte contre le petit
nicolas pour usurpation d'identité
mais en espagne rares sont ceux qui
osent parler car le petit nicolas
posséderait des informations extrêmement
compromettantes sur la plupart des gens
puissants qu'il a manipulé la justice
s'intéresse notamment un possible
scandale sexuel qui impliquerait
plusieurs très hauts dirigeants
pour en savoir plus nous nous rendons
dans une boîte de nuit branchée de la
capitale où le jeune nicolas avait ses
habitudes
c'est dans cette discothèque qu'il se
fait prendre en photo avec le secrétaire
d'état au commerce rails mais les gas
les deux hommes auraient entretenu un
rapport intime
selon le portier de la boîte de nuit que
nous filmons à son insu ce mot registre
pas
[Musique]
nicolas est homosexuel le ministre si
ils ont été longtemps ensemble
ça a commencé quand nicolas et est
encore à doha il ne le prenait pas au
sérieux il avait des relations sexuelles
à quatre ou cinq
mais le move est intelligent il a tout
noté photographier et filmer et
maintenant elle tire le ministre et ses
gens importants par les couilles des
choses horribles vont sortir dans la
presse
pour garantir son avenir nicolas aurait
en effet truffé de caméras la villa où
il a reçu pendant des mois
grand patron un politique et toutes les
élites du pays
il a déjà diffusé quelques documents
gênants comme cette photo du président
du plus grand syndicat de patrons
assoupi dans le canapé
invité sur un plateau de télévision
il y a quelques semaines nicolas a
menacé de dévoiler des vidéos bien plus
terrible j'ai des documents très
sensibles commencé à sensible à quel
point il affecte toutes les institutions
beaucoup de gens vont devoir
démissionner aujourd'hui nicolas et en
liberté en attendant la fin de l'enquêté
son procès continue d'entretenir sa
légende et son portefeuille
ces différentes interviews lui aurait
déjà rapporté plus de 100000 euros